now this is interesting because we've
got another triangle that looks exactly
the same
actually I literally copied and pasted
through the triangle okay so it is the
same triangle but what's the difference
now we've got we've got what it words
yeah yeah we've got coordinates now it's
the same problem so that means that all
this logic that we used before I can use
it again I just need to know how it
applies to this coordinate geometry
situation ok so I try I'm still trying
to work out this distance from A to B
that distance there okay
now being it that's the distance I'm
after when we used the previous question
to work out this distance we use the
other two can you see that if you know
these two you can get to that one using
Pythagoras said okay so I'm gonna do the
same thing here yeah that's right I need
to know okay what's what's this distance
right I'm gonna have to work that out
and then after work out or what's this
distance in the previous question there
were five and twelve but I don't know
what they are here all right so let's
give this a go now how do you go about
working out this vertical distance okay
now it's to do with rise over run right
it looks it looks just like that doesn't
it okay you can see that it goes from
now this is up this is one one isn't it
okay so rise is about that is about the
X or the y coordinate it's the y
coordinate which is six right so you
started from one right that's the y
coordinate and you go up to six that's
what you're telling me okay you went
from one to six so the difference
between one and six is five right 6
minus 1 is 5
okay that's what this distance is okay
another way to say it that's the rise
okay does that make sense
say again
like a yeah good so with booth passed
the rise the vertical part here I want
to do the run the horizontal part well
I've got to go from one all the way over
to ten you can see it's the horizontal
part there so one to ten that's two
minus one so that distance is going to
be nine okay so this is good now I have
these two distances in here right I'm
gonna do the same thing I did before I'm
gonna do Pythagoras have enough space
I'm gonna write the hypotenuse squared
is equal to what's it equal to you guys
six when it's six come from I actually
want this length
so five squared plus 9 squared B guy
that's Pythagoras theorem yes when I get
a 10 from its it's the coordinate live
its provided there that Tim yeah okay
I'm not there yet you don't you're
getting heavy
so yeah question is it it's okay we're
gonna do a few more examples you'll say
alright so we're gonna get to the number
now five squared is 25
9 squared is 81 so you add those
together and it looks like 106 okay now
this is a bit Messier unfortunately I'm
hundred six is not a square number okay
but that's no big deal all we have to do
is write the square root of 106 that's
it that's my song and it's AB units and
don't forget we only took the positive
one because a B is a length okay so
since a B is a lake or a distance it has
to be positive okay now I can it's
finally we're finished but just for the
sake of curiosity if you have a
calculator there let's just approximate
this what would we get everyone 10.0
great
that's two decimal places we'll just
leave his tip what you don't you okay
that's fine okay that's just so that we
could say well how long is it does that
look about right I think it's fine yeah
okay all right good so you've seen we've
moved from a regular triangle with
Pythagoras it's okay I'm going to be
back and say which you don't and then we
looked at we saw the same kind of
triangle but when it's all in terms of
coordinates okay so when you want to
find these distances you've got to
understand how to use the coordinates
carefully okay so don't leave that there
while you catch up with the writing so
if you're finished radius you can turn
over and have a look for the rest of you
I'll give you another 30 seconds or so
and then on turn over question about the
next one the first one yeah what do you
know you're gonna have to wait you're
going to come over there or you can ask
me now yeah yeah sure okay
so which one is your question right
which one and the answer is we've got
the question so if the question says
nothing so if they don't say right then
they don't think they if they want you
to approximate they have to tell you one
decimal place or two dozen ways or three
significant figures right so you look at
the question if it doesn't say anything
just just leave it if they say
approximate that's when you go to the
next line and we've gone to two they
might do one or whatever so look at the
question okay yeah
that means approximately equals
approximately because it's not exactly
but it's pretty cool